I believe I was an employee of Adobe for about two days at the same time as Sean Parent was an employee. Oh, cool. Yes, because I joined a small company in the middle of the 90s, whose name escapes me. And they were a subsidiary of Aldus who made Pagemaker. And their CEO had spent a year climbing mountains in South America. And that's when they did a deal
我想我和 Sean Parent 在 Adobe 的时候，大概有两天时间的重叠。哦，太酷了。对，因为我在 90 年代中期加入了一家小公司，名字我记不清了。他们是 Aldus 的子公司，Aldus 曾经开发过 Pagemaker。当时他们的 CEO 花了一年时间在南美洲爬山。就在那个时候，他们达成了一笔交易
to join with Adobe. But it was more a takeover than a joint merger. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 154, airport lounges, meeting C++, CodeDive, and more. It's interesting, though, because when you were mentioning C++ being a multi-paradigm programming language, that got me thinking about, you know, I do think it's like a fundamental thing to C++'s nature. And it's sort of hard to put our finger on exactly why, what is fundamental about it. But I think that insofar as multi-paradigm languages go, I think that C++ is almost without a rival. Like there are other languages that do other things a lot better than C++,
决定加入 Adobe。但与其说是联合合并，不如说是一次收购。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 154 期，机场休息室、Meeting C++、CodeDive 等内容。不过这很有趣，因为当你提到 C++ 是一种多范式编程语言时，这让我想到，我确实认为这是 C++ 天性中非常根本的东西。而且我们很难确切指出原因，究竟是什么让它如此根本。但我认为，就多范式语言而言，C++ 几乎没有对手。就像有些语言在某些方面比 C++ 做得好得多一样，
but C++ has ability to let you do what you want and combine different paradigms, different styles is sort of unmatched. And in fact, I think some could even make the argument that it is really the only multi-paradigm language. No, I mean,
但 C++ 让你能够随心所欲并结合不同范式、不同风格的能力是无与伦比的。事实上，甚至有人会认为它真的是唯一的真正多范式语言。不，我的意思是，
multi-paradigm to the extent that c++ is but like i could list off to you like 20 different ones that support two paradigms really well like scala is a great example it's functional but also object oriented but like the the unique thing about c++ is like the multi and multi-paradigm the n is much greater than two you know know, is it six? Is it seven? Is it 10? You know, who knows? I think that one of the key things that about C++ that makes it successful is that C++ lets you almost seamlessly combine very low level and very high level code that you can do things that are very close to the metal. And maybe you're not doing them directly, but you might be using something that somebody else wrote, some library that somebody else wrote that's very close to the metal. This sort of gets to C++'s performance mission. And that you can take
多范式达到 C++ 这种程度的，但比如我可以给你列举 20 种很好地支持两种范式的语言，比如 Scala 就是个很好的例子，它是函数式的，同时也是面向对象的。但 C++ 独一无二的地方在于，在“多范式（multi-paradigm）”中的这个“多”字，它的数量远大于二，你知道的，是六个？七个？还是十个？谁知道呢？我认为 C++ 成功的一个关键因素是，C++ 让你几乎无缝地结合非常底层和非常高级的代码，你可以做非常贴近硬件的事情。也许你不是直接在做，但你可能在使用别人写的东西，别人写的非常贴近硬件的库。这这就触及了 C++ 的性能使命。你可以拿
those things that are like very low level pointers, you know, hardware things, all the nastiness and unpleasantness that we have in the world of systems programming. And you can wrap them up in abstractions, and then you can deal with those abstractions at a very high level. You know, and it's like, think about some of the code that I was writing today for this algorithm I've been working on. And it's just that mix of, you know, I have some places where I'm, you know, hacking on pointers. I'm casting stuff around. I'm, you know, there's undefined behavior, there's all sorts of unpleasantness. But then that's boxed up and encapsulated and then I can use it in a very
那些非常底层的东西，比如指针，硬件相关的东西，我们在系统编程世界中拥有的所有讨厌和令人不快的东西。然后你可以把它们包裹在抽象中，你就可以在非常高的层面上处理这些抽象。你知道的，想想我今天为我一直在研究的算法写的一些代码。它就是这种混合体，你知道，有些地方我在折腾指针。我在到处进行类型转换，你知道的，这里有未定义行为，有各种各样令人不快的东西。但随后这些都被打包和封装了，然后我就可以以一种非常
functional way. And I can use it with some very high level algorithms and I can use it with generic programming and I can use it with some object-oriented abstractions. And that's really what makes C++ successful and sort of unique, is its ability for you to do the low-level stuff, to do the systems programming stuff, and also use higher-level concepts and ideas and paradigms. And also to be able to not just do, you can take a bunch of different libraries or a bunch of different APIs,
函数式的方式使用它。我可以将它与一些非常高级的算法结合使用，可以与泛型编程结合使用，还可以与一些面向对象的抽象结合使用。这正是 C++ 成功且独一无二的地方，在于它让你能够做底层的事情，做系统编程的事情，同时也能够使用更高级的概念、想法和范式。而且不仅仅是做到这些，你还可以获取一堆不同的库或一堆不同的 API，
a bunch of different system interfaces, all of which may have a different style, may exist at different levels of the abstraction. And you can work with all those at the same time in the same program. Like when I was writing code today, I was using Cub and Cuda, which are very low-level things. And at the same time, I was also using the C++ standard library and Thrust, which are very high-level things.
一堆不同的系统接口，它们可能都有不同的风格，存在于不同的抽象层级。你可以在同一个程序中同时处理所有这些。就像我今天写代码时，我在使用 Cub 和 Cuda，这是非常底层的东东。与此同时，我也在使用 C++ 标准库和 Thrust，这些是非常高级的东西。
And it was very seamless for me to interoperate between those two. And it was seamless for me to, in the places where I needed to, to drop down to a very low layer in the stack in the places where I was like, I really don't like care that much to just be like, all right, I'm just going to like use like a stood vector here. Like, that's fine. Like, I don't need,
对我来说，在两者之间进行互操作是非常无缝的。对我来说，在需要的地方，我可以顺畅地向下掉落到栈的非常底层；而在那些我其实没那么关心的部分，就可以直接说：“好吧，我在这里用一个 std::vector 就行了。”这完全没问题，我不需要，
I don't care about the specifics of how this memory is allocated. Like, I don't need to be programming c style here i just need like i need this part of the code to work and run and i can just like create a stood vector and use it right here alongside all this other you know low-level garbage that i'm doing while you were talking there about doing that and switching around, I thought of why C succeeded ahead of Pascal. I had thought of another reason,
我不在乎这块内存是如何分配的具体细节。我不需要在这里进行 C 风格的编程，我只是需要这部分代码能够工作和运行，我就可以直接创建一个 std::vector，并把它和我在做的所有其他底层垃圾代码一起使用。刚才你在谈论做这些事情以及各种切换时，我想到了为什么 C 比 Pascal 成功。我想到了另一个原因，
and this will please you, Bryce. C has the preprocessor, Pascal did not. And so with C, you could, with the preprocessor you can generate, like if macros, you could, with the preprocessor, you can generate, like, if macros, you can generate code. Similarly, templates did that for us in C++, which meant that we didn't need reflection as much for a long time. And Pascal didn't have that ability. Yeah. And especially when you're doing systems programming, the preprocessor,
这会让你高兴的，Bryce。C 有预处理器，而 Pascal 没有。所以对于 C 来说，通过预处理器你可以生成——就像宏一样，你可以通过预处理器生成代码。类似地，模板在 C++ 中为我们做到了这一点，这意味着很长一段时间里我们对反射的需求没那么迫切。而 Pascal 没有这种能力。是的。特别是当你进行系统编程时，预处理器，
the C preprocessor is such a powerful and useful tool. When you're dealing with different platforms, different compilers, different implementations, like, yes, I know it has lots of problems, and I know it has lots of foot guns, but especially if you look
C 预处理器是一个如此强大且有用的工具。当你处理不同的平台、不同的编译器、不同的实现时，是的，我知道它有很多问题，我也知道它有很多容易走火的地方，但特别是如果你看看
at the era where C came out and the early days of C and C++, the preprocessor is an incredibly innovative and powerful tool. And the fact that it had limited guardrails meant that you could do almost anything with it, which was both a pro and a con. There's another language that was around, which was based on Fortran called RAT4. I think it stood for Rational Fortran. And that was basically Fortran plus the preprocessor. And the preprocessor would run through, you'd have a certain set of standard constructs and macros,
C 诞生时的那个时代以及 C 和 C++ 的早期，预处理器是一个极其创新和强大的工具。而且它几乎没有限制，这意味着你可以用它做任何事情，这既是优点也是缺点。当时还有另一种语言，基于 Fortran，叫做 RAT4。我想它代表 Rational Fortran（理性 Fortran）。那基本上就是 Fortran 加上预处理器。预处理器会运行，你拥有一套特定的标准结构和宏，
and they would just produce Fortran code underneath. And that was, I think it was either Kernighan or Ritchie wrote a book with all the examples in RAT4. Interesting. We will find a link and put it in the show notes for and and you can't you can it is interesting that that there is today um a lot of people do use fortran with the c pre-processor um ah okay so that is that is a thing that is it yeah that it it is a thing right right for isn't it? It is a thing. Right, right. For better and for worse.
它们会在底层直接生成 Fortran 代码。我认为，要么是 Kernighan 要么是 Ritchie 写过一本所有示例都在 RAT4 中的书。很有趣。我们会找到一个链接并把它放在本期节目笔记中，而且——而且你不能——你可以——有趣的是，今天——嗯——很多人确实在使用带有 C 预处理器的 Fortran——啊，好吧，所以这也是一回事——对，这确实是一回事——对吧？它是一回事。对，对。有好的一面，也有坏的一面。
Or maybe it's... I know that it's... I don't know if there's a bespoke preprocessor for Fortran. If it is, it's very much based on the C preprocessor, but I think that it's... My recollection is that it's just the cp processor for fortran code i think like if you do like dot fpp files with like g fortran i
或者也许它是……我知道它是……我不知道是否有专为 Fortran 定制的预处理器。如果有的话，它很大程度上也是基于 C 预处理器的，但我认为它……我的记忆是，它就是用于 Fortran 代码的 C 预处理器，我想就像如果你用 gfortran 处理带有 `.fpp` 后缀的文件，
think it'll run the cp processor first i was gonna say we're we're like half an hour we appreciate jonathan i realize you're on Dublin time, too, so this is a lot later in the evening for you than it is for us. So thank you for spending so much time with us. This has been – Yeah, it's like 9 p.m. there, yeah. Yeah. I know that because I just got an awesome new watch
我想它会先运行 C 预处理器。我本来想说，我们——大概半小时了。我们很感激 Jonathan，我知道你也是都柏林时间，所以对你来说，现在比对我们要晚得多。非常感谢你花这么多时间陪我们。这真是——是的，那里大概晚上 9 点了，对吧。对。我知道，因为我刚买了一块很棒的新手表，
that shows me all the time zones. You know what? We'll leave that one in. That wasn't long enough to speed up, so we'll leave that one in. Don't worry. Don't worry. There will be a lot of talk about the watch in future episodes. While we were talking about the success and, you know, the multi-paradigmeness of C++ and
它能显示所有时区。你知道吗？我们把这个留着。这不够长，不需要加速，所以我们把这个留着。别担心。别担心。在以后的节目中会有很多关于这块手表的讨论。当我们讨论 C++ 的成功以及，你知道的，C++ 的多范式特性时，
why it's so great, I will first ask a question, Bryce. You have given your endorsement to Beautiful C++. However, I know you haven't read the book, but to the book but i've been very clear that i've not read the book but to what extent did what what amount of uh what is the word perusing or skimming did you do before you gave your endorsement what i said in the past is that it is the style of book the organization of the book is this is the type that I would find useful. I'm not generally a huge fan of programming books. And the reason is that most of them are like a journey. Like, you need to start at the beginning of the journey and then you need to like end at the end.
为什么它这么棒，我首先要问一个问题，Bryce。你已经对《Beautiful C++》表示了赞同。不过，据我所知你并没有读过这本书。但对于这本书，我一直很明确地说我没有读过这本书——但在你表示赞同之前，你究竟对它进行了多少程度的、用什么词来形容——浏览或略读？我过去说过的是，它是这种风格的书，这本书的组织方式正是我会觉得有用的类型。我通常不是编程书籍的超级粉丝。原因在于它们大多像是一段旅程。就像，你需要从旅程的起点开始，然后你需要在终点结束。
They're like a linear story to some degree. and the type of book that i would find useful is um because i'm a very hands-on sort of person um and i like to sort of like get knowledge sort of like on the fly as i need it and so something that's more like a reference manual or like a collection of independent lessons or a collection of independent guidelines um is something that's closer to to being, you know, the material that would be useful for me. Something like effective C++, which is like a series of like concrete recommendations or beautiful C++, which is a series of complete recommendations. Those I find more useful because if I'm, you know, wondering about like, oh, what's the best practice for X? I'm more likely to be able to use++. If it's like a traditionally laid out C++ book, maybe there's a chapter on classes,
它们在某种程度上就像一个线性的故事。而我会觉得有用的那种书是……因为我是一个非常注重动手实践的人，我喜欢那种随用随学、即兴获取知识的方式，所以有些东西更像是参考手册，或者是一系列独立的课程，或者是一系列独立的准则，这更接近于对我有用的材料。像《Effective C++》这样包含一系列具体建议的书，或者《Beautiful C++》这样包含一系列完整建议的书。我觉得这些更有用，因为如果我……在想诸如“哦，X 的最佳实践是什么？”之类的问题，我更有可能能够使用 C++。如果是那种传统布局的 C++ 书籍，也许里面有一章讲类，
and maybe the answer would be there. But something like effective C++ or beautiful C++, there's probably like a concrete line item about like constructor explicitness that I can just go look up. I'm not going to – in this one, like I'm just not going to read an entire book. All right. I might be interested enough to go and – We got to cut you off. It's taking too long.
也许答案就在那里。但像《Effective C++》或《Beautiful C++》，里面可能会有一条具体的条目讲诸如构造函数的 explicit（显式）关键字，我可以马上去查。我不会——在这个里边，我就是不会去读整本书。好吧。我可能会有足够的兴趣去——我们得打断你。这花的时间太长了。
This is a long-winded answer. Yeah. You didn't actually answer my question. I've been very clear. I didn't read the book. I know. I said it was the type of book that I could find useful. Yeah, you gave it your endorsement.
这是一个冗长的回答。是的。你实际上没有回答我的问题。我很清楚。我没有读过这本书。我知道。我说过这是我会觉得有用的那类书。是的，你对它进行了背书。
I did give him my endorsement. I skimmed through things. It looked good. So here we go. That was the answer I'm looking for. Did you actually read, like, did you read the table of contents? You skimmed it? Like, did you read a full chapter like i've read i've read a couple of the
我确实对它进行了背书。我浏览了一下内容。看起来不错。所以就是这样。这就是我想要的答案。你真的读过吗，比如，你读了目录吗？你略读了？比如，你读完整的一章了吗？——我读过、读过几篇……
um okay uh of the like concrete uh like rules um so i have not i mean i i've seen the cover uh which is why i did not endorse i can't endorse something you know i haven't checked out but uh one of the people on i think it was episode 150 or 151, commented that Adam Leventhal, the individual that was saying that the book was an advertisement for Russ, was a little bit validated by the following. And he's got three screenshots. Section three is named, stop using that. Section two, don't hurt yourself, is where we present guidelines for preventing
嗯，好的，嗯，关于那些具体的、像规则一样的东西……所以我没有，我的意思是，我看过封面，这就是为什么我没有背书——我不能背书我没有查看过的东西。但是，节目组的某个人，我想是在第 150 期或 151 期时评论说，亚当·莱文塔尔（Adam Leventhal）曾说这本书其实是给 Rust 做广告，这个观点在一定程度上被随后的内容证实了。他有三个截图。第三章名为：停止使用那个。第二章：不要伤害自己，在这里我们提供了在编写代码时防止人身伤害的准则。然后第四章是：正确使用这个新东西，就像我说的，我没有看过这本书，但这是一个铁的事实。尽管 C++ 很棒、是多范式的，但如果最新的书籍推出的章节标题居然叫“不要伤害自己”，
personal injury while writing code. And then section four is use this new thing properly, which, like I said, I haven't checked out the book, but it's a solid thing. Even though C++ is great, multi-paradigm, if the most modern books are coming out with chapters entitled don't hurt yourself um you know at least it's at least it's being honest oh look at this jonathan we've had we've had i mean loony was nothing special because loony comes on the podcast all the times but this is uh jonathan's this is we met when we were in yes you did this is Bumblebee and we are looking after her while her owners are away in Japan for three years
你知道的，至少它——至少它很诚实。哦，看这个，Jonathan，我们有——我们有——我的意思是露妮（Loony）没什么特别的，因为露妮经常上播客，但这是——这是 Jonathan 的——这是我们在——是的，这是大黄蜂（Bumblebee），当她的主人去日本三年不在家时，我们在照顾她。
oh wow but she's a lovely dog aren't you Bumblebee and you have I mean we will put some links because I do have I do believe I tweeted I'm not actually sure if I did no I don't think you did I think the one
哦，哇，但她是一只可爱的狗狗，对吧，大黄蜂？你拥有——我的意思是，我们会放一些链接，因为我确实相信我发过推特，我其实不确定我是不是发了——不，我觉得你没有——我想唯一的
concrete section of beautiful C++ that I can recall having read actually read or not read but looked through is the chapter on default arguments versus overloading
《Beautiful C++》中我能想起来自己读过、确实读过或者说不是读过而是翻阅过的具体部分，是关于默认实参与函数重载那一章。
because one I was trying to figure out how to structure something in a project, but two, I was wondering about what's the state of the, like, what's our design guideline for C++ standard library proposals? And I think there's been a couple other chapters that I've similarly looked at but all right back to bumblebee and your other pets okay well i have you have you have two kittens that are absolutely two cats yeah yeah sirius and remus um yes and then we have five alpacas, which are also lovely. Let me see if I can remember the names. I know one was Merlot. Very good.
因为第一，我当时在琢磨怎么在项目中组织某些东西；第二，我在想，C++ 标准库提案的设计准则现在的状态是什么样的？我想还有其他好几章我也类似地翻阅过。不过，好的，回到大黄蜂和你的其他宠物身上。好的，我有——你有——你有两只绝对是……两只小猫，对吧？小天狼星（Sirius）和莱姆斯（Remus）。是的，然后我们还有五只羊驼，它们也很可爱。让我想想我能不能记住它们的名字。我知道其中一只是梅洛（Merlot）。非常好。
Yeah. Alpha male. I want to say, I mean, a lot of them were wine names. I want to say Chardonnay. Yes. I think those are my two best guesses. I'll guess Sauvignon Blanc, but I don't think that's right. No, no.
对。阿尔法雄性。我想说，很多都是葡萄酒的名字。我想说霞多丽（Chardonnay）。是的。我想这是我最好的两个猜测。我猜是长相思（Sauvignon Blanc），但我觉得不对。不，不。
What were the other three? Merlot, Malbec, and Montepulciano are the black alpacas. And then we have Chablis is the white, and Chardonnay is fawn-colored. So, yeah. Very adorable. If Bryce ever happens to be in Dublin, you've got to go and see the alpacas. They're very adorable. If Bryce ever happens to be in Dublin, you got to go and see the alpacas. They're very adorable. And it's still true.
另外三只是什么？梅洛（Merlot）、马尔贝克（Malbec）和蒙特布齐亚诺（Montepulciano）是黑色的羊驼。然后白色的叫夏布利（Chablis），还有一只是山羊色（fawn-colored）的霞多丽（Chardonnay）。所以，是的。非常可爱。如果 Bryce 哪天碰巧去都柏林，你一定要去看看那些羊驼。它们非常可爱。如果 Bryce 哪天碰巧去都柏林，你得去看看那些羊驼。它们非常可爱。而且这依然是真的。
It is a one world hub. So it is entirely possible that we could be connecting in or travel to Dublin. Yeah, indeed. But the lounges aren't great in Dublin, I have to say. I have heard that, yeah. But the lounges aren't great in Dublin, I have to say. I have heard that, yeah. Yeah. In fact, the Aer Lingus lounges, which I'm still a member of, I get free use of them, but there's so be a flight that would leave from London City Airport on an A318. It was an all business class flight. And they couldn't take off from London City Airport
这是一个全球枢纽。所以完全有可能我们会在都柏林转机或前往都柏林。是的，确实如此。不过说实话，都柏林的休息室不太好。我听说过，是的。不过说实话，都柏林的休息室不太好。我听说过，是的。是的。事实上，爱尔兰航空的休息室，我依然是会员，我可以免费使用它们，但曾经有一趟航班是从伦敦城市机场出发，用的是 A318。那是一架全商务舱航班。它们无法从伦敦城市机场起飞
with enough fuel to fly all the way to New York. But they wanted to be able to leave from London City Airport because it's near the city. And so what they would do is they would fly from London City Airport to, I think to Shannon. And they would land there and there was a US customs pre-clearance facility. And so they would land to refuel. But while they were refueling, you would go through US border control and customs, and then you would get back on the plane and then it would fly to New York, I think to JFK, although presumably it could have gone to LaGuardia because you were already pre-cleared. And then you'd have a direct flight but not a nonstop flight from London City Airport to New York.
并携带足够飞往纽约的燃油。但它们希望能够从伦敦城市机场出发，因为那里离市区近。所以它们会怎么做呢？它们会从伦敦城市机场飞往，我想是香农（Shannon）。它们会在那里降落，那里有一个美国海关预清关设施。所以它们会降落加油。但在加油期间，你要通过美国边境管制和海关，然后你再回到飞机上，接着它会飞往纽约，我想是肯尼迪机场（JFK），尽管大概也可以去拉瓜迪亚机场（LaGuardia），因为你已经完成了预清关。然后你就能搭乘直飞航班，但不是不经停航班，从伦敦城市机场飞往纽约。
That was if you wanted to fly for many years, the first few times I went to the States I would get on in Dublin airport they would stop in Shannon every plane that was heading to the States from Dublin would stop in Shannon and we would troop off the plane go through duty free troop back on
如果你想飞的话，很多年前就是这样。我去美国的前几次，都是在都柏林机场登机，它们会在香农经停。所有从都柏林开往美国的飞机都会在香农经停，然后我们得下飞机，去免税店，再重新登机。
actually I think we no we actually would have also gone through emigration US emigration in Shannon which was a lot better than in the states i think yeah um and um yeah that's that's what we do and then they finally stopped that um so you could actually fly direct so there's now u.s immigration in dublin as well um yeah yeah yeah yeah because we've this is what are we whatever let's go to where this is over two
其实我觉得我们——不，其实我们当时还会在香农通过移民局，美国的移民局，这比在美国境内要好得多，我想。是的。嗯——是的，我们就是这么做的。然后他们终于取消了这个规定——所以现在都柏林也有美国移民局了。——是的，是的，是的，因为我们——这是什么，不管怎样，让我们进入——现在已经过了两个多小时了，
hours now right yeah we're just past the two hour mark which means i mean i thought this was going to be probably two or three episodes at this point it's probably going to be four episodes which if you're curious jonathan is going to put you at at the top because i t keep track. And that's going to put you, you're going to be tied with Kate Gregory, Chandler Carruth, Zach Lane, and Patricia Oss. Wow, I'm in incredibly good company. Yeah, it's a good list to be on. Is number one is Sean?
对吧？是的，我们刚过两个小时大关，这意味着——我的意思是，我本来以为这大概会有两三集，此时此刻它可能会变成四集。如果你好奇的话，Jonathan，这会把你排在最前面，因为我在做记录。这会让你——你将与 Kate Gregory、Chandler Carruth、Zach Lane 和 Patricia Oss 并列。哇，我和非常优秀的人并列在一起。是的，这是一个很棒的榜单。第一名是 Sean 吗？
Yes, so that is, those four individuals are tied for seventh place, seventh to tenth, as most number of episodes. Who's number two? Above that is, oh yeah, let's play a little guessing game. Actually, actually, I'm so glad that we didn't wrap this up because, you know, we've been trying to kind of wrap this up for the for the og listeners and that might be that might mean that you've been listening for two plus close to three years or it might mean that you only started listening a month ago but you've been going through the back catalog uh jonathan you have actually been mentioned i want to say in at least two but like maybe upwards of four or five episodes because very early on you were the individual that created the bingo
是的，所以那——那四个人并列第七名，从第七到第十，也就是上节目集数最多的人。谁是第二名？排在上面的是——哦，对，让我们玩个猜谜游戏。其实，其实我很高兴我们没有就此结束，因为，你知道的，我们一直试图为老听众收尾，这意味着你可能已经听了两年多快三年了，或者意味着你可能是一个月前才开始听，但你一直在补回溯目录。——Jonathan，其实你已经被提及过，我想至少在两集里，甚至可能多达四到五集里，因为在很早的时候，你就是那个制作宾果卡（bingo cards）的人。
cards and this is from like two and a half years ago i think that you made two different bingo cards i did two or three bingo cards yeah and i think i didn't even know initially it was you or maybe the first time i read it off because your twitter handle is like you can spell it out for us or pronounce it it's n-i-n-k-i-b-a-h which is somali for the man i did not know that uh i did know that your twitter was how do you pronounce it do you know ninky bar ninky bar yeah and more people i just i just checked you i don't understand why more people aren't following you on Twitter. More people should follow him on Twitter. Oh, thank you. We will have the bio.
这大概是两年半前的事了，我想你做了两张不同的宾果卡。我做了两三张宾果卡，是的。而且我想一开始我甚至不知道那是你，或者也许第一次我读出来的时候，因为你的推特账号是——你可以为我们拼出来或发音，是 n-i-n-k-i-b-a-h，在索马里语里意思是“那个男人”。我当时不知道这一点——我确实知道你的推特是——你怎么发音来着？你知道的，ninky bar。ninky bar，是的。而且更多的人——我刚刚查了一下，我不明白为什么没有更多的人在推特上关注你。更多的人应该在推特上关注他。哦，谢谢你。我们会把简介放出来的。
The reason I chose that was that I did a year of linguistics after my computer science degree. And one of the courses we had was we had an eight-week course in Somali as a non-Indo-European language. And it's got very interesting characteristics. It's a tone-based language, so that would probably suit you, Connor, having learned Mandarin. It sounds like you were already a chess player at this point. Yeah, yeah yeah yeah yeah because i was gonna say uh if you were taking a a year of linguistics that's and uh you know you got the the game board that's like it's like a scrabble player waiting to be born but if you're already bitten by the chess bug i can understand
我选择这个的原因是，我在计算机科学学位之后花了一年时间学习语言学。我们上的课程之一是为期八周的索马里语课程，作为一种非印欧语系语言。它有非常有趣的特征。它是一种基于声调的语言，所以这可能很适合你，Connor，你学过普通话。听起来你当时已经是一个国际象棋棋手了。对，对，对，对，因为我本来想说，如果你花了一年时间学语言学，而且——你知道的，你拿到了棋盘，那就像是一个天生的拼字游戏玩家；但如果你已经迷上了国际象棋，我完全可以理解。
no no no chess chess is my thing and i and i'm now i'm now a roving chess diplomat um so i i get to i get to to vote for ireland in the world chess federation elections every every well the elections are every four years yeah but um yeah so that's i do follow you on twitter and i see your your chess tweets every once in a while and yeah yeah i don't have the knowledge to appreciate them at the level that i'm sure they can be appreciated at but yeah yeah so i i i suspect i suspect i should really split and have two twitter handles one for chess and one for everything else but indeed but the other thing is like twitter is about to die and i got it i got a vector of bull gave me an invite to blue skies but nothing's happening on there so I do have a
不，不，不，国际象棋是我的事，我现在——现在我是一个到处游历的国际象棋外交官。所以我——我有机会在国际棋联的选举中为爱尔兰投票，每隔——好吧，选举是每四年一次，是的——但——是的，所以我确实在推特上关注了你，我偶尔会看到你关于国际象棋的推特。是的，是的，我没有那种知识水平去以我确信应该有的那个高度去欣赏它们。但——是的，所以我——我猜——我猜我真的应该分流，拥有两个推特账号，一个专门用于国际象棋，另一个用于其他所有事情。确实如此。但另一件事是，推特快要死了，我收到了一个邀请——Bull 给了我一个加入 Bluesky 的邀请，但在那上面什么也没发生。所以我的确有一个
Mastodon thing that I set up a long time ago but Mastodon seems very complicated about you know where do you live so where do I go for to continue my my Twitter well the thing is that Twitter's been about to die for
Mastodon 账号，是很久以前设置的，但 Mastodon 似乎非常复杂，关于“你住在哪里”，那我该去哪里继续我的——我的推特呢？问题是，推特已经快要死掉
you know a while yeah I think we just The thing is that Twitter's been about to die for, you know, a while. Yeah. I think we just, I don't think anything else, I think this is it. I think if Twitter goes away, Twitter goes away, and we all find something else to do with our spare time. I don't think that it's something that can be easily reproduced or replicated. Fair enough, fair enough.
好一阵子了，对吧。我想我们只是——推特已经快要死掉好一阵子了，对吧。我想我们只是，我觉得没有别的——我想就是这样了。如果推特消失了，推特就消失了，我们都会找别的事情来打发空闲时间。我不认为这是一个可以轻易被复制或重现的东西。也对，也对。
My guess is that it's going to be one of these mastodon or blue sky things i mean uh what from talking to the oxide and friends folks they're all on the mastodon um site and honestly i was thinking like i'm i'm happy to switch when something is competitive but like i just discovered that you can't quote tweet on macedone from listening to like a oxide and friends old episode and like they were saying it because it discourages uh you know being mean but like i quote tweet all the time when i just see some talk or something and it's it's typically positive uh and also to like my history sometimes i tweet stuff just so that I have an image that I can include in a talk later. And like if Twitter dies,
我猜它会是 Mastodon 或 Bluesky 里的某一个。我的意思是，从跟 Oxide and Friends 的那些家伙交谈来看，他们全都在 Mastodon 网站上。老实说，我在想，当有什么东西具有竞争力时我很乐意切换，但我刚刚发现你在 Mastodon 上不能引用转发（quote tweet）——我是从听 Oxide and Friends 的旧节目中了解到的，他们当时讨论这个是因为它能阻止——你知道的，刻薄的言论。但我经常进行引用转发，当我看到某次演讲或其他什么东西时，而且通常是积极的内容。而且还有，比如我的历史记录，有时我发推特纯粹是为了保留一张图片，以便以后在演讲中使用。如果推特死了，
do I lose my entire history of like commentatory logic tweets and discovering APL? I think you can generate a big large file of your whole complete history and download it. So no is the answer. And then it's like each of them are like HTML files. Don't worry, somebody has scraped the Twitter data sufficiently
我会失去我关于评论逻辑推特和发现 APL 的整个历史吗？我想你可以生成一个包含你完整历史的大文件并下载它。所以答案是“不会”。然后就像它们都是 HTML 文件一样。别担心，有人已经充分抓取了推特数据，
that I'm sure you'll be able to get to find it. Yeah, I mean, it's still irritating though that like I'm gonna have to jump through some hoops in order to get like, I can't just go to the Twitter search, type at code report, and then the keyword that I know will, you know, like sometimes I just, I know that Google
我确信你一定能找到它。是的，我的意思是，这仍然很令人恼火，我必须跳过一些圈套才能得到——我不能直接去推特搜索，输入 @code_report，然后输入我知道能……你知道的，有时我只是——我知道谷歌
Translate will get me one of those images and I can just copy and paste it. But yes, I mean, it does seem like Twitter is, it's dying a slow death. I mean, I'm still hopeful that, you know, things will turn around, but it definitely has not been trending. Anyway, Connor, Connor Bryce, I have one last story and then we'll finish here. I believe I was an employee of Adobe for about two days at the same time, at the same time as Sean parent was an employee.
翻译会给我其中一张图片，我可以直接复制粘贴。但是，是的，我的意思是，推特看起来确实正在缓慢死亡。我的意思是，我仍然希望事情会有所转机，但它绝对没有呈现上升趋势。无论如何，Connor，Bryce，我还有一个故事，然后我们就结束。我相信我在 Adobe 做过大约两天的员工，同时——与 Sean Parent 同时作为员工。
So yes, because I joined a small company in the middle of the 90s, whose name escapes me. And they were a subsidiary of Aldus, who made Pagemaker. And their CEO had spent a year climbing mountains in South America. And that's when they did a deal to to um to join with adobe but it was more a takeover than a joint like merger um and so we were all in the all the programming team were in um seattle learning about windows 95 or chicago as it was then and on the thursday evening we got told we were all fired because because because uh we weren't going to be lit we wouldn't we didn't we weren't living in um i guess it was where is where's adobe is it in silicate somewhere in san
所以是的，因为我在 90 年代中期加入了一家小公司，名字我记不清了。他们是 Aldus 的子公司，Aldus 曾经开发过 Pagemaker。当时他们的 CEO 花了一年时间在南美洲爬山。就在那个时候，他们达成了一笔交易，去加入 Adobe，但与其说是联合合并，不如说是一次收购。所以我们所有人——所有的编程团队都在西雅图学习关于 Windows 95（当时叫 Chicago）的知识。然后在周四晚上，我们被告知我们全都被解雇了，因为——因为——因为我们不会留在——我猜那是——Adobe 在哪里？是在硅谷的某个地方，在圣何塞？
jose san jose yeah right so if you didn't want to if you didn't want to work in San Jose, you weren't working for Adobe anymore. And so, yeah, that was the end of us, sadly. So I suspect for about a week, Sean and myself were coworkers. Yeah, look at that. I mean, that's a perfect way to end Slash. We've got to's a perfect way to end slash we got to do the quiz though we got to do the quiz so is it uh do i ask both i'll ask both of you so you know tied in seventh were the four individuals i mentioned earlier we know sean is number one at 11 11
圣何塞，对。所以如果你不想——如果你不想在圣何塞工作，你就不能再为 Adobe 工作了。所以，是的，这就是我们的结局，真令人遗憾。所以我猜在大约一周的时间里，Sean 和我是同事。是的，你看。我的意思是，这是一个完美的结尾——斜杠（Slash），我们必须得做个小测试，我们必须做个小测试。所以——是我问两人吗？我会问你们两个，所以你知道，前面提到那四个人并列第七名。我们知道 Sean 是第一名，有 11 集。然后我告诉你们数字：第二名是 9 集，第四名是 6 集，然后第五和第六名都是 5 集。所以我可以说，Sean Baxter 可能上了 5 或 6 集？Sean Baxter 只排在第 11 位，有 3 集。
episodes and then i'll give you the numbers number two is nine episodes number four is six and then five number five and six are both five episodes so i would say sean sean baxter is probably in five or six episodes sean baxter is only he's ranked 11th at three episodes oh oh wow in last year it's it's there have been a couple there have been one or two people who've been on twice i just can't remember who actually wait is that right you might be you might be correcting my spreadsheet here let's go to tags search for uh because sean we definitely has he only been on that one time i thought i thought you had i think we only recorded with him once um yeah i think that was we did the one time when you went over to the apartment so so so i think that ben dean has because you recorded with him at c++ now and then we also had him on separately
哦！哇。在去年，有那么一两个人上过两次，我只是记不清到底是谁了。等等，对吗？你可能正在纠正我的电子表格。让我们去标签里搜索一下……因为 Sean，我们确定他只来过那一次吗？我以为你——我以为你——我想我们只和他录制过一次。是的，我想那是当你们去公寓的那一次。所以——所以我认为 Ben Dean 有——因为你在 C++ Now 上和他录制过，然后我们后来又单独请了他一次，所以他肯定至少上过六或七次。是的，Ben Dean 是数字——其实我意识到这些都错了一位——所以……
so he's got to have been on at least six or seven yeah ben dean is number actually i realize these are all off by one so um but yes ben dean is number is number two ah okay i i have no idea about number three oh that's actually there's something ada ada prefers one based indexing to zero based indexing oh i do actually like that that is i i'm in the minority opinion amongst array language devs i think because both j and bqn are zero index yes zero indexed i haven't spent enough time programming in one indexed languages to know um but i i think i'm i think i might prefer it because mentally i think one base to zero base yeah mentally i think about the the first element not yeah yeah zero well i mean one of the i have a number of examples but the uh probably the top one i'd have to think
不过是的，Ben Dean 是数字——是第二名。啊，好的。我对数字三一无所知。哦，实际上有一点——Ada 喜欢基于 1 的索引，而不是基于 0 的索引。哦，我其实很喜欢那样。我是极少数喜欢基于 1 索引的数组语言开发者之一，我想，因为 J 语言和 BQN 语言都是基于 0 索引的。是的，基于 0 索引的。我没有花足够多的时间用基于 1 索引的语言编程来了解……但我——我想我可能更喜欢它，因为在精神上，我会去想第一个元素，而不是……是的，是的，0……我的意思是，我有很多例子，但顶尖的一个——我得稍微想一下——那就是，如果你获取一个数组的长度，然后你做——其实这还不是长度，因为长度会给出正确的结果。但如果你做什么来获取，比如说，某个索引，然后你想对包括该索引及之前的首个元素执行“take（取）”操作。如果你——你知道的，你的第一个索引是 0，然后你执行“取 0 个元素”，那会返回一个空列表。而实际上你大多数时候想要的是第一个元素。你就像是想要检索与该索引相对应的内容。所以就像是，
about it a little bit is the fact that if you take the length of an array and then you do and it's or it's not actually length because length will give you the correct. But if you do something to get like, you know, the index of, and then you want to do a take on the first, you know, elements up to and including that. If you, you know, your first index is zero and then you do a zero take, that gives you back an empty list. Whereas really what you want is most of the time you want that first element. You like, you want to retrieve the thing that corresponded to the index. So it's like, you know,
比如说，我想要数字数组中的第一个奇数。那只是 1, 2, 3, 4, 5。如果我构建我的掩码（mask），那将会是 1, 0, 1, 0, 1。然后我执行“where（其中）”，这会给我索引。在 APL 中将是 1、3 和 5，但在 BQN 中将是 0、2 和 4。然后我从 where 的结果中取出第一个值，在 BQN 中将是 0，在 APL 中将是 1。然后当你用该值执行“take”时，APL 会给你返回第一个奇数，但 BQN 会什么都不给你返回，因为在将它与某些算法（如 take 和 drop）一起使用时，你必须给该索引加 1。无论如何，
say I want the first odd element from like an array of numbers. That's just one, two, three, four, five. And so if I build up my mask, that's going to be one, zero, one, zero, one. And then I do a where, which is going to give me the indices. In apl it'll be one three and five but in bqn it'll be zero two and four and then i take the first value from where it's going to be zero in bqn and one in apl and then when you do a a take with that value apl will give you back the first odd but bqn will give you back nothing because you have to add one to that index when using it with certain algorithms like take and drop anyways Anyways, we're getting sidetracked. I can get to five episodes
无论如何，我们扯远了。我可以通过抛出这个问题来凑够 5 集。我在脑子里想，你发现自己将被排上名次，我想它是并列第六，但你本可以与第四和第五名并列。所以，是的，我们漏掉了第三名、第四名、第五名，
by just throwing in the question. I was thinking in the back of my head, you found out you were going to be ranked and I think it's tied with six, but you could get tied with the fourth and fifth individuals. So yeah, we're missing number three, number four, number five,
他们每人都有 6 集和 5 集。我的意思是，他们可能正在听并大喊“叫我的名字！你怎么能把我忘了？”我的意思是，其中一个人拥有最多的集数，而且我们曾经一次录制了 5 集——我的意思是，你现在正接近这个数字——而且我们说过会请他再来。第一个提示是，他是一位男士，第二个……
who are six episodes and five episodes each i mean they are probably listening going shout my name how can you forget about me i mean one of them has the highest number of episodes and we recorded five episodes in one sitting which i mean you're you're approaching right now and we said we'd have him back on there's a first hint is that he and the second And we said we'd have him back on. The first hint is a he, and the second hint is we said we'd have him back on for the holiday special. How could that be?
而且我们说过会请他再来参加节日特别节目。那会是谁？
I have no idea. The guest that made the most fun of Bryce while recording. Oh, JF? We've never had JF on. We're not going to have JF on. JF's on a rival podcast. I'm just listing people who are good at making fun of me. I don't know.
我完全不知道。在录制时拿 Bryce 开玩笑道歉最多的嘉宾？哦，JF？我们从来没有请过 JF。我们不会请 JF 的。JF 在一个竞争对手的播客里。我只是在列出那些擅长开我玩笑的人。我不知道。
Wait, Zach. It's got to be Zach. Yeah, Zach Lane is number five. He was the one that we, one episode, five. One recording, five episodes. All right, number four. It's actually number three and number four. Tristan Brindle and Tony Van Eerd.
等等，Zach。一定是你，Zach。是的，Zach Lane 是第五名。他是那个——我们曾有一集录了五集。好吧，第四名。其实是第三名和第四名：Tristan Brindle 和 Tony Van Eerd。
I was going to say, has Tony, have we recorded with Tony twice? I mean, you weren't there for one of them, which is why you probably forgotten. Because the first time we recorded with Tony, he showed, we recorded live during a virtual C++ Now way back in 2021. Because I think 2020 was canceled is that dinner um anyways bryce has disappeared from the screen i know i i'm still i mean this is why i got the microphone yeah we need to get you one of those cameras like the cisco webex cameras that follow you around so while you're up and about. Anyways, thank you so much for taking so much time, Jonathan. This was an absolute blast.
我本想说，Tony，我们跟 Tony 录过两次吗？我的意思是，其中有一次你不在，这就是为什么你可能忘了。因为我们第一次跟 Tony 录音时，他展示了——我们在 2021 年虚拟的 C++ Now 期间进行过现场录音。因为我记得 2020 年被取消了——那是晚餐吗？无论如何，Bryce 已经从屏幕上消失了。我知道，我还在这儿——我的意思是，这就是为什么我有了麦克风。是的，我们需要给你弄一台那种思科 Webex 摄像机，它能在你走动时跟着你。无论如何，非常感谢你花这么多时间，Jonathan。这绝对是一次极好的体验。
We are going to have to reconvene sometime, whether that's in Dublin or outside. What's the name of the small city? Mullingar. Mullingar. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And it's a very lovely, lovely place. Very much removed from, you know,
我们以后得找个时间再聚聚，不管是去都柏林还是其他地方。那个小城市叫什么名字？Mullingar（马林加）。Mullingar。对，对，对。那是一个非常可爱、非常迷人的地方。远远远离了——
we're talking about being cyborgs and whatnot, but there's a sense of tranquility out where you live. There is, yes, yes. And we do have fiber broadband, which was installed at great expense by the Irish government last year. So it's pretty good. I mean, that's really all you need, right?
我们刚才在谈论当赛博格之类的话题，但在你住的地方有一种宁静的感觉。确实有，是的，是的。而且我们有光纤宽带，这是爱尔兰政府去年花了大价钱安装的。所以它相当不错。我的意思是，这真的是你所需要的全部，对吧？
As long as you get the internet. Absolutely. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I'll be in Meeting C++ in Berlin. So anybody who's a listener to your podcast and that's happening next month. So please, I'll be helping out.
只要你能上网。绝对的。是的，是的，是的。我将去柏林参加 Meeting C++。所以任何听你们播客的人——下个月就要举行了。所以拜托，我会去帮忙。
I'll be helping Jens run the show. So this is actually, depending on how we cut this now, because we are now at two hours and 21 minutes, will this become four or will this become five episodes? Meeting C++ is taking place the 12th to the 14th, which is a Sunday to a Tuesday.
我会帮 Jens 运营展会。所以这实际上是——取决于我们现在怎么剪辑这段，因为我们现在的时长已经达到了 2 小时 21 分钟，这会变成 4 集还是 5 集？Meeting C++ 将于 12 日至 14 日举行，那是从周日到周二。
And the fourth episode is going to be coming out on the 10th. So if we cut this into five, you will become, you will be tied with Zach Lane and Tony Van Eerd, but people are going to be hearing you say this after Meeting C++ has come out. So there is a kind of incentive, although will people be able to sign up two days before the conference happens? I don't know. Maybe, maybe not. Well, I presume everybody's bought their ticket by now. Yeah. I forgot to tell you, I'm going to Switzerland in November.
而第四集将在 10 号播出。所以如果我们把它剪成 5 集，你将与 Zach Lane 和 Tony Van Eerd 并列，但人们听到你说这句话时，Meeting C++ 已经结束了。所以这算是某种激励，尽管人们能在会议开始前两天注册吗？我不知道。也许能，也许不能。好吧，我猜每个人现在都买好票了。对了，我忘了告诉你，我 11 月要去瑞士。
Is that because you're also going to meetings Z++? Or this is just a random fact? No, no. I got to go to CERN to talk to CERN. You want to come to Switzerland? Oh, CERN? Are you going to CERN? Yeah.
是因为你也要去 Meeting C++ 吗？还是这只是一个随机的事实？不，不。我要去 CERN（欧洲核子研究中心）跟 CERN 谈谈。你想去瑞士吗？哦，CERN？你要去 CERN 吗？对。
That's fantastic. In Geneva or near Geneva. It's brilliant. I was there a few cern yeah that's fantastic in geneva or near geneva it's brilliant yeah i was there a few years ago it's fantastic i am very excited don't put your head in the particle beam it's not a good idea i will i will try to remember that do you know this first hand experience i know because i asked the question has anyone ever put their head in the beam or what would happen and there was an engineer that unfortunately got his head in the beam. And he went blind, I think, within two days. And he didn't have a very long life after that.
太棒了。在日内瓦还是日内瓦附近？这太棒了。我几年前去过那里——CERN，太棒了。我非常激动。别把你的头伸进粒子束里，这不是个好主意。我会——我会尽量记住这一点的。你知道这是第一手经验吗？我知道，因为我问过这个问题：“有没有人把头伸进过粒子束里？或者会发生什么？”有一个工程师不幸把头伸进了粒子束。我想他不出两天就失明了。而且他之后的寿命也不是很长。
So. Jeez. Wow. I did not know that. I thought it was going to be like you got laughed out of the room of like what a silly question but uh nope nope that had a different ending to that story than uh then i thought it was going to well i know you had a great time in switzerland connor you'd come with me i mean uh i'm not sure i've done so much traveling this year i mean you're always traveling but i i've spent way more time on the road than i uh yeah i typically like to
所以。天哪。哇。我不知道。我还以为你会像被笑话一样赶出房间，觉得这是个愚蠢的问题，但呃，不，不，那个故事的结局和我想的不太一样。嗯，我知道你在瑞士玩得很开心，康纳，你跟我一起来吧。我的意思是，呃，我今年没有去过那么多地方旅行。我的意思是，你总是到处旅行，但我花在路上的时间比我……是的，我通常喜欢的那样……
and if i mean if i was going to be in europe in november i feel like i'd want to go to But I've spent way more time on the road than I typically like to. And if I was going to be in Europe in November, I feel like I'd want to go to a meeting C++, go to a conference. I mean, what are the dates you're going to Switzerland? Maybe you can swing by, pop by. No, it's like November 26th. Is that post-code dive? You're also going to code dive then or no? No, originally I told them no, I can't go
而且如果，我的意思是如果我十一月要在欧洲的话，我觉得我想去……但我花在路上的时间比我通常喜欢的多。而且如果我十一月要在欧洲，我觉得我想去参加 Meeting C++，去参加一个会议。我的意思是，你去瑞士的具体日期是什么时候？也许你可以顺便过来，露个面。不，大约是 11 月 26 日。那是 Code Dive 之后吗？你那时候也要去 Code Dive 吗？还是不去？不，我本来告诉他们不，我去不了
because I thought it overlapped with the committee meeting. But then I realized that it didn't. But it was it was it's just too much travel because if I was going to Code Dive, then I would be out for three weeks and then Thanksgiving. And I basically it would just be too much. So, yeah, well, next year, if you're listening to this either on... If you're listening to this on November 10th, check out Meeting C++. There might be tickets still available. And CodeDive,
因为我以为它和委员会会议冲突了。但后来我发现并没有。不过这实在是太累了，因为如果我要去 Code Dive，我就会出去三周，然后接着就是感恩节。基本上这就太多了。所以，好吧，明年，如果你在……收听这个节目。如果你在 11 月 10 日收听这个节目，去看看 Meeting C++。可能还有票，而 CodeDive，
I don't actually know the exact dates, but I know that is later on. They just posted the agenda, actually. Yeah. Well, let's look it up while we're here. CodeDive, it's one of my favorite conferences. They hold it in a movie theater, which is such a cool vibe i am kind of bummed to not going because it looks like a really cool conference and yeah and it's
我其实不知道确切的日期，但我知道那是比较晚的时候。其实他们刚刚发布了议程。是的。好吧，趁我们现在在这儿查一下吧。CodeDive，这是我最喜欢的会议之一。他们在电影院里举办，这种氛围太棒了。没能去我其实有点沮丧，因为看起来真的是个很酷的会议，而且是的，它
not just c++ so you get to go see some python some javascript uh you can stick to just c++ talks if you want but yes 16th of november which actually now that i think about it if this if i was going to say probably if but if it's getting if this episode is on November 17th, you can still check out Code Dive. Turns out it's too late. So anyways, we've been saying goodbye for like half an hour now. Yeah. Thank you so much for taking the time, Jonathan. Take care, guys.
不只是 C++，所以你还能看到一些 Python、JavaScript，如果你愿意，也可以只听 C++ 的演讲。但是是的，11 月 16 日。其实仔细想想，如果我说的话……如果这个节目是在 11 月 17 日播出的，你或许还能去看看 Code Dive。结果发现已经太迟了。总之，我们已经道别了大约半个小时了。是的。非常感谢你抽出时间，乔纳森。保重，伙计们。
It was great, great being here. And I hope to see you in the real world sometime soon. Soon, hopefully. Ciao. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com for links to any of the things we mentioned in today's episode,
能来这里真是太棒了。希望不久的将来能在现实世界中见到你们。希望很快。再见。请务必在您的播客应用程序中或访问 ADSPthepodcast.com 查看本期节目的shownotes，其中包含我们今天节目中提到的任何事物的链接，
as well as a link to the GitHub discussion where you can leave comments, thoughts, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast.
以及通往 GitHub 讨论区的链接，您可以在那里留下评论、想法和问题。感谢收听。希望您喜欢，并祝您有美好的一天。质量低，数量高。这就是我们播客的标语。
It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这不是标语。我们的标语是充满信息点缀的混乱。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。